[inaudible]
do you think lawsuits are the
answer to stop some of this stuff?
I'm also realizing right now that would
our runway to fix this is becoming
perilously short. Like we're getting
to the best pretty damn quick.
The 2020 election is right around the
corner and that seems to me to be what
this is all ramping up to.
Absolutely. The Covington case was
such a glaring example of that.
So I was on vacation
in Mexico. Yeah. Okay,
so let's just go all in on
Covington right now. Yeah,
so it was a little town north of port
of are out there just hanging out too.
You know, going through
Twitter and [inaudible] son
of a bitch, try on Twitter,
on vacations. We'll see what happens.
And so I see Maggie Haberman,
the premiere reporter for the premiere
news publication in the country covering
American politics. New
York Times. Yeah, exactly.
Basically calling for the expulsion of a
bunch of kids that she's never met that
she doesn't know based on an event she
didn't see. And I found that so shocking.
I was like, we're crossing a whole
new line now. If we're going to go,
it's one thing to go after what
somebody said 10 years ago.
That's problematic on its own terms.
We'll get,
we'll get to that in a little bit too.
That's what we have
statutes of limitations for,
but the a is that you're not going to be
held responsible for what she did when
you're 10, but the or when you're
20, when you're 40. But the here,
these kids were who were just going up
to DC to be part of the pro life march.
Uh, and usually the pro life march at five
at family participate in that. They're,
they're just having fun.
You know, they're not mean.
They're not out there harassing people.
They're just expressing what they
believe. A, these kids are having fun.
Probably the first time ever to Washington
DC there by the Lincoln memorial was
beautiful memorial and all of a sudden
they start getting harassed out of the
blue and they have likely never met
the black Hebrew Israelites. Right?
Some of us that have
no what's coming every,
I lived in New York City for many
years. Every by these guys, many times,
every insult, known demand.
It's like really? They're
almost like an insult comic.
If the routine is so extreme, it's like
they find something going the next,
then the next thing the next day,
like bad don Rickles. Oh, exactly.
Exactly the worst version, right? It's
all you combined Farah Khan with Don Rowe.
Yeah. Right. So,
but these kids have no ideas and they
have an African American friend that's
there with them and the he's being
attacked and so they start defending him.
They started attacking, making various
anti gay slurs there. They question,
they respond back to that in defense
of people who are gay. So I was like,
these are in that mean kids.
These are kids trying to handle
the shocking environment.
They decided to go internal and start,
okay, let's not deal with these guys.
Let's do our school tiers. One of their
school cheers as the old Haiku, as a,
as the Haiku dance, which is the Great New
Zealand rugby team. All black. Yeah. I,
in fact two weeks before it's shown
it to my son because I was like,
look at how awesome. It's awesome.
It's all over youtube by the way.
Anyone can watch it.
And absolutely.
When I first saw it in
the movie with Matt Damon,
that's the greatest sports
dance I've ever seen. In fact,
before I want to get inspired
by something, I'll just
put it on and go get ready.
Yeah. So the, so they
do that as part of it.
That's why when the kid's tearing his
clothes off and it's right after that,
it's happening,
then all of a sudden the native American
comes up with some friends and he's
doing the drums. So two
thirds of the kids think, oh,
he's joining in because we just did
the Iq thing. Oh, this is great.
And what do they know?
The most popular, uh,
native American sports thing they know
is the, is the Tomahawk Chop from, uh,
from the Florida, stayed from Kansas
City chiefs and Indian Atlanta Braves.
All the places where they're familiar.
And there, it's right on the,
on the border of the Kentucky,
Ohio border.
So the kind of programs they'd be
familiar with, that's what they see.
Not Nobody's mocking him. Nobody's
chanting, build the wall out of.
Nobody's blocking him.
Nobody's surrounding him.
And then at one point they started, some
of the kids start to figure out, okay,
something's odd. Because some of
the people behind him are saying,
go back to Europe. And it's like,
where did that come from? Uh,
and then they realize something's weird.
Then they just leave.
And then as they're on their bus home,
all of a sudden their lives are being
upended and they're not being up ended by
just some random bot accounts who started
their being offended by Kathy Griffin
who's calling for them to be doxed.
They're offended by Maggie Haberman
calling for them to be expelled.
They're upended by Matthew Dowd, who's
on ABC, who was, it was a prominent,
a Catholic on ABC saying that
things need to happen to these kids.
And in Navarro, who is saying bad
things need to happen to these kids,
almost the entire media is,
and then you have Hollywood celebrities
calling for them to be put through the
shredder for them to be attacked
for them to be. You had uh, uh,
a writer who claimed to be
part of Saturday night at
nine live say she's going
to extend sexual favors for anybody
who physically assaulted these people.
And I was like,
these are probably the kids.
These are, by the way, these are
blue checked verified people,
these are all of them.
Generally the people that Twitter says
you should pay attention to that we've
verified that. We validated that we've
authenticated that we've authorized.
And uh, it, Twitter and social media
does almost nothing about this. In fact,
they run with the fake news story and
these kids lives are almost over in five
seconds based on a misleading
video. Um, and so I saw it and I,
uh, when I first saw the video I was like,
oh, that's going to be fake news story.
Just cause you know, DC politics, you
know, you know lefty protest culture,
you know the chances that a bunch of
Catholic kids came up and found a lefty to
harass isn't that real high and Washington
DC say that happened in a small town
in Alabama. Okay, maybe uh, but there's
like this story doesn't make sense.
And so I was like, okay,
that will probably blow over.
And that was well getting on
a plane to go to boost areas.
Then I get to the booze and
see these things and I'm like,
they're going to destroy
these kids' lives.
And I realize if they
think if they can do this,
they can do anything to anyone at anytime,
anywhere.
And that's exactly.
So then you started tweeting about it
alongside a couple of other people and I
thought a couple of other people in the
legal world and I thought, all right,
I've got to talk to this guy because
if this one doesn't get corrected,
which fortunately thanks to you and it's
ongoing, you and several other people,
it is getting corrected. But I thought
if this one doesn't get corrected,
if we let them demolish high
school students, we're done.
We are done. So can you catch us up on
sort of where, where this is all at now?
So when I did initially is I first just
put out a tweet and said if anybody
wants to sue Maggie Haberman now represent
it for free. And I was just agitated,
just ticked off.
And I didn't tune into Twitter until
like two days later when I came back and
all of a sudden it blown up and I'm
getting all these and I'm like, okay.
I realized that this was
becoming very high profile.
And so I go on Fox and my goal is to
get everybody to start to re retract,
start to back up, start to
retail, the different story.
And unfortunately almost
all the institutional media
starts to backtrack fast.
So to be clear,
you did not want to go the legal route.
Actually you are giving
everybody, man, I saw you do this.
You gave them the chance guys,
just delete the tweets.
Did you even ask them to issue apologies.
I don't even remember that I said was,
I said that everybody got 48
hours to do one of three things,
either correct or delete or apologize,
just do something to correct the record
and let me to her credit congress woman
Omar, who usually has no problem saying
anything under God's green earth. Uh,
she did,
she did it within an hour,
but she only did it because
roll call covered my story.
So his role called covered my stories.
Like, Oh, maybe I can get sued. AndW ,
you know, took it down. By the way,
right before that she had sent out a tweet
linking them to white supremacist and
a whole bunch of others. Yeah, a
whole bunch of false information.
She labeled them in a whole new,
unique ways.
They'll leave it to her to figure
out a way to do that. The, uh,
this is a member of Congress,
by the way.
Then you have Senator Warren is running
for the presidency of the United States
repeating false statements
about these kids.
Well that's because she's native
Americans. Yeah. Yes, yes, exactly.
She has to stand up for her.
Trump the level,
like they portrayed him as a
native American elder. Well,
I clerked for native American tribes. I
worked for one of these old school lefty,
one of the best trial lawyers in the
country. And I was like, hey. I was like,
I don't think he's an elder
of that particular tribe.
Then I realized they were just confusing
the terms because he's elderly.
They were going to call him an elder.
I was like,
that's an insult to all the most native
American elders are very carefully
selected. They take their job very
seriously. In fact, their court system,
if we had an ideal court
system in the world,
it would be the native
American elder system.
I'd be all for it because there's 12,
12 people sit around and you come and
you tell him your dispute and they try to
find a remedy that will satisfy everybody
and they try not to be too punitive.
They try not to be too, uh, too
involved. They just try to say, okay,
what's caused this problem?
How can we address the cause of it?
And they're focused on reconciliation.
How can we bring people together so it
doesn't happen again and people don't
feel bad at the end of it.
Not Great for your profession,
but exactly a much better system.
I'd be all for it. I mean I'm happy,
happily forfeit my law degree
to see that system put in place,
have the 12 members of your community
get to decide these kinds of disputes and
find ways to put people back together
and protect all the things that matter to
us rather than deepening the division
and the bitterness that exists.
And the legal system often creates that.
People often leave it even when they
win unsatisfied. And so the uh, so,
but so they put this guy in that context,
there's like,
it wasn't a Vietnam war veteran.
The was really not really being accurate.
They're trying to script a narrative,
trying to tell the story,
but doing it to these kids and include
the message was if we can destroy them,
we can destroy you.
It was an ultimate exemplar mechanism
of media narrative structure and that's
why I volunteer to help them out. And so
now represent 14 families in Covington.
Oh about 90% of the people I went
on Fox and said 48 hours notice,
just clean it up and we'll be done.
And even after that,
and giving people additional opportunities
and additional opportunities,
please take it down, please. That none
of the family members want to sue.
They don't want to deal with the
nightmares of the legal system.
They don't have to go through
all that hassle hurdle. Um,
but they want the record corrected and
they don't want to happen to anyone else.
That's it. And so I was like, let's
set a record. Let's set a pattern.
Let's set a precedent year that
this can get corrected and remedied,
that he can't do this to these kids.
You can't do this to these people
that you do have standards.
You have to be bound by those standards.
You have to be governed
by those standards,
and you have to act
according to those standards.
For those that refuse to do anything
about it, they're going to be sued.
Yeah. Because so some of them still
left the tweets up or did an apology.
Kathy Griffin. Matthew Dowd,
oddly enough, Maggie Haberman, uh,
Senator Warren, uh,
congresswoman Holland. Uh,
those are the five highest profile
examples of people who refuse to correct.
When you see a mob descent,
it's a little,
it's a little hard to figure
out how coordinated it is,
whether it's group think,
is this coming from the top?
Is this organic?
As much as you've had to
deal with these things.
And especially since you dealt with the
most recent one that's still unfolding
right now, what's your take? Is it,
is it a little bit of everything?
It's two different things.
One is there,
they've started to greenlight mob culture.
That's what it was scary here because
this started out with a bot account who
was spreading it through sort of liberal
ideological culture who is trying to
create an online model.
But the reality is that online mob
would have never reached critical mass,
at least as it related to these kids
without the blue check mark crowd saying,
Yay, Yay, Yay. And
that's the problem there.
The green light for online mob behavior
and that's why they have to be stopped
and they have to correct their actions
or they have to be remedied in court
because they are the ones
that are permitting it and
expanding it. And for them,
I don't know how often it's deliberate
and how often to cultural mindset,
I used to call it cotton ball culture.
So in the south people used
to go to the cotton ball.
They're part of the privileged classes
when they're 16 and 17 and they're sort
of incorporated and acculturated
to a certain mindset.
So it's not that they all
get together and conspire,
but that they have a certain
point of view that's,
that's been created by
the culture they share.
And I think there's some of them online
mob culture that's been festering over
the past half decade,
decade.
And the worst part of it is that continued
to be green light by institutional
people or people with big
platforms and big power.
Are you shocked also how the racial
element has become so blatant?
So it was like these kids are white.
So you know,
they have punchable faces or excusing
the black Israelites to quizzes because
they're black. So they can call
these kids faggots. And that's okay.
Even though you're supposed
to defend gay people.
But I guess if it's black people,
you know,
they created this oppression
Olympics intersectional too. Yeah.
This intersectional lunacy.
So are you just shocked how,
how solidified that is in
so many people's brains
coordinator for like two
different reasons. One,
whenever I see people do it or raise it,
my instinctual view is I was like, well,
what does that person actually
done for civil rights?
So like when I'd been
attacked, I'm like, well,
I've done civil rights for 20 years.
I've done very difficult cases in very
difficult advocating for civil rights.
So I was like, is this person really
out there trying to help protect people?
Or is it somebody who wants to,
uh,
social brownie points and social prestige
point for being on the right political
side? Um, and that's 95% of them.
These are people that aren't actually
doing anything to improve the wellbeing of
African Americans.
And Latinos in this country.
The second part of it is it's
become social prestige to uh,
out people that are on that ever
particular disfavored political class.
And it happens to be the right now are
disfavored political classes are by
people are men are people of certain
sort of parts of the country,
certain political arena.
Dacian kids wearing Maga hats.
Exactly. I was like, that's
the same sort of bigotry.
The bigotry doesn't know color bigotry
is bigotry and this has just racial
bigotry disguised as a,
as tried to protect people.
They're not out to protect people.
They're out to hurt and harm people and
they just want to feel morally justified
when they do it.
So when you now have to have to move
forward on this lawsuit that you're saying
you're going into not
really cause you want to,
you're giving these
people a chance to go out.
How does this even work logistically
when you're going after people that have
nothing to do with each other other than
they all did it on the same platform.
So we're going to bring
it as a class claim.
So all the plaintiffs will be combined.
So all 14 kids will be one group of
plaintiffs and all the defendants will be
combined.
So the uh,
so you can combine the defendants
together when there's a common nucleus of
facts and there are behaving
in a coordinated way,
even if it doesn't rise to the level of,
say,
illegal conspiracy or aiding and abetting,
which it may in some of these instances,
the effect of it is you can add them
together because for judicial economy
purposes,
they're all part of the same event.
And it's easier for one judge to preside
over all the cases combined then the
cases differently. Uh,
and so it's interesting,
some of the left media's client use use
of these kinds of defamation claims has
done used this exact procedure and it's
time to use the exact procedure back the
other way.
You gotta be careful what you wish for.
Exactly.
So let's talk a little bit about what's
going on with Tucker Carlson right now.
Now Tucker has been on this show,
I go on his show every couple of weeks.
I find them to be a decent guy.
We have political disagreements that we
have expressed to each other publicly
before,
but I think he's on the right side,
especially when it comes to the free
speech stuff now. Now media matters,
which you mentioned already there,
they're going after him.
They're finding old audio clips on a
shock. Jock, a Bubba, what's his name?
Bubba. Bubba Gump, Blah
Blah. So then Bubba,
is there any, I know it's got bubble
and the bubble, that's something, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Whatever it is in
effect a Howard Stern, like figure.
Exactly where I was thinking.
I tweeted something the other day that
I wish Howard stern was maybe a little
more engaged in these days.
Ndas, I don't begrudge him. He's,
he's lived through a lot and he's had,
he's been a great fighter on our
side of the free speech thing,
but it's like if he was to take the 30
years of stuff that politicians, actors,
Comedians, authors, musicians,
everybody has said the crazy sexual
acts that had been done in that.
So you all those things and said
you what this is all part of life,
right? All say things we get
in atmospheres. Where you
joke differently this way,
then you would that way.
All of these things,
I would love to help have him
aiding us right now in this fight.
So that's just one piece of this.
But putting that aside,
media matters is now digging into old
things of, of talkers. And you know,
he apparently he said Faggot.
There were a couple of other things and
they're trying to make it sound like
he's racist and he's for abusing kids
and all of these things and I wonder what
his legal recourses now
he's not apologizing.
That's one thing which I think
that's pretty good for the,
if you're going to stand against the
mob, don't apologize. But also if there,
because their goal is
just to destroy this man,
their goal is in some sort
of legal justice, right?
Their goal is their goal isn't
to help anyone. Exactly. Right.
Unless they're doing something
that I can't figure out.
Their goal is to destroy a man.
And if you could destroy a man,
you can destroy an idea and you can get
all sorts of other people to shut up.
So what the hell do we do?
It's very much a censorship shaming
campaign designed to marginalize his
audience and marginalize him from having
access to his audience and to be an
example to future people
so that they won't, Hey,
you better not come after a big tech,
which is really what distinguishes Tucker
from anyone else on Fox or anyone else
in the political conservative space.
He's probably the lead high profile
person taking on big tech in this country.
One of the leading guys saying,
I think you're telling me I should have
you on retainer. Is that where exactly?
That's what's happening. It's a
systematic, it's institutional. It's in,
it's deliberate and it's obvious.
So like I first got it familiar with
this aspect of it in the context of
representing Alex Jones,
because I was trying to figure out why
do people think he said a bunch of stuff
that he actually didn't say or did things
that he actually didn't do or think
90% of what he said was
this as opposed to that.
And it had found out watching Joe Rogan
that it was actually a media matters
thing that Joe Rogan himself
walked. He's like, oh no,
I saw this media matters thing was
like who would trust media matters.
It's like they, they're politically
motivated, they're partisan oriented.
They take various forms of like people
complain about secret corporate cash and
dark money. Media matters has tons
of secret corporate cash and dark.
Is that, is that a big problem right here
that the nonprofits now are probably,
I don't know all the laws
related to nonprofits,
but they're probably in almost every
political case stepping beyond their
boundaries?
They definitely are and then
what's happening is they're
becoming clearly their
partisan organizations,
so here you have,
nobody would think media matters is
nonpartisan. I'm pretty sure they did
go after a joy reed on cable news when
her whole thing went down about the anti
gay blog posts.
Exactly. They've defended all kinds
of people on the left who said,
I'll come far worse things and at least
are politically ideologically aligned
with the left are supposed to be in the
first instance and this is the left set
of standards.
That's something you say 20 years ago
somehow means you can never have a public
platform ever again.
For the rest of your human existence.
This is not an American standard.
This is not a conservative standard.
This has very much a left standard.
The,
but they don't apply it to
their own people ever at all.
I mean some of the things Joe Biden
has said over the years, yeah,
he's the leading Democratic candidate for
the presidency and then guy opened his
mouth and crazy stuff came over.
Half the things that Trump says now,
although he says them sloppily,
are the exact same things that Obama
said about immigration and Clinton said
about immigration and Dianne
Feinstein in the rest of them. So the,
it's extraordinary for the,
for this sort of one side of application,
but clearly Tucker is a target because
Tucker is willing to take on big tech and
the goal is they're testing when can
we use something in the person's past.
But what's extraordinary about all
of this, what unites all of it,
whether it's the Covington
case or the Alex Jones case,
is that you have people who
are unwilling to debate ideas.
It's all about if you disagree with them,
then they're going to
target you as an individual.
They're going to make your life
difficult as an individual.
They're going to harass you as an
individual stock. You as an individual.
I've already been to
Tucker's house by the way,
precisely when his wife was there and
had no clue what was going on and they're
banging on the door and that was a
reason why Fox went off Twitter for an
extended time period. Cause Twitter
would do nothing about it. I mean the,
the extraordinary
discrepancy in disparity.
Everybody can witness and everybody
and people were like, Tim,
pools on the left can
say this is problematic.
This is kind of obvious what you guys are
doing and recognize how problematic it
is because they're not going to
stop there. It's like Alex Jones,
they're not going to stop with Alex Jones.
They're going to use it as an example to
try to go after everyone else to scare
and intimidate everyone else. You
better not be in the independent press.
You'd better not be in
the independent speech.
You better not be sharing a dissident
narrative or we're going to be able to
demonetize Yardi platform
you a d bang you, uh, or,
or defame you routinely and
regularly and get away with.
And that's why we need equalize the
playing field. And, but for Tucker's case,
what he could do,
uh,
is he could potentially go after
media matters for misrepresenting or
mischaracterizing the set of events.
They have a habit of putting out a video
that decontextualizes what happened.
They did it to Alex Jones.
They would take them where he's talking
about this subject put into a minute, uh,
where it looks like he's talking
about Sandy Hook is actually not,
he's talking about something else.
And they would say,
these are all of the statements. So my,
they've likely done the same thing to him,
but there's limited remedies.
I also saw one of,
I think it was one of the
directors of media matters.
I actually retweeted it saying,
if you think this is bad,
we've got a lot more or something to
that effect. And I thought this, they're,
they're telling you how evil they are
because they're saying we are releasing
this information in a calculated way
to destroy a man. We're not just,
we're not just doing it for publicly like
we found all this stuff and we're just
going to put it all out there on day
one because people should know about his
path.
It's like we're going to keep the monster
being fed so that it can keep feeding
on correct and it's why are
they so scared of ideas?
If they think Tucker's wrong, an ideas
debate his ideas, why attack him?
Why especially why attack him on something
he said 20 years ago on a shock jock
show?
There's also something crazy you could do.
You could actually pick up the remote.
You're not going to believe this.
There's a button on that thing that
allows you to scroll up or down.
Have you seen this thing? Exactly. I mean
if you don't like what you're hearing,
you don't have to listen to it. If you
think it's wrong, you should engage in.
Years ago, Professor Lash, great historian
passed away some years ago. He said,
the reason why we expose our ideas and
debate other people isn't necessarily to
persuade them.
It's because they're going to expose
ideas that there are weaknesses in our
argument. And we often research
a topic when somebody says,
we got told that must be wrong and we go
and find out about it would become more
informed by engaging in the public
debate process. And that's, that's good,
that's healthy.
But these are people who fundamentally
don't believe in free thought,
free expression and free speech.
Fundamentally,
they believe that you should
have the right thought,
not that you should have free thought,
you should have the right expression,
not that you should have free expression.
They've combined sort of the inquisitional
Catholic church with like 1920s
communists and they've integrated
the two in their approach.
And they're using our legal system and
using our political system and their
superior power in the cultural,
uh, areas of influence,
whether it's Hollywood,
whether it's big media,
whether it's big tech to suppress and
oppress those people who have different or
dissonant views than them,
including people on parts of the left.
So I mean people like temple is being
called a Nazi because he appears on Joe
Rogan and ask a few questions at Twitter.
I mean this is insanity.
So that's actually,
I was going to go somewhere else,
but let's jump there for a second.
So like for example,
when I had Tim Poolan last week,
there were verified people on Twitter
calling Tim a Nazi and Mia Fascists or me
and Nazi and Tim, a fascist. I, I've
mentioned this before. I've had an ah Ha,
I grew up around Holocaust survivors.
I lost family on both my
mom and my dad's side.
Okay.
Now again,
I'm the free speech guy so I
don't want to sue these people.
Is there some legal remedy for this
if I was someone different than I am?
Correct, yeah, there is. Because for
example, I took a couple of years ago,
the Cassandra Fairbank's case,
it gets a, and one of the I,
one of the reasons I took it is,
yeah,
I want send a former lefty, by the way,
she's now all Trump, but former lefty.
I had drinks with her one night. She gave
me her full on lefty, lefty, lefty, lefty.
Yeah, exactly. Part Puerto Rican.
And she was accused by Emma Roller,
a flashing on white power gesture
and this was the universal,
just became a white power
that was like so and so.
She was on Twitter and he's like, I
got to stop this, can somebody help me?
And I said,
I'll,
I'll help for free because I liked the
area of the case and thought needed to
stop this because they're used to being
able to say, I'll call someone and Nazi,
I'll call someone a racist and
that's not actionable at law.
And I wanted to change that.
I want him to say when you make very
specific statements about someone's belief
structure that someone can interpret in
a jury can objective Lee verifies either
true or false that I think that
should be something you can sue over.
So I brought the case in DC and we
couldn't meet the actual malice standard,
but the court said yes, saying someone
is a racist in a particular way,
like saying it's a white power gesture,
you can be sued for the
United States for liable.
And lies and under the
defamation laws of DC,
which are more restrictive
than a lot of other laws.
So that's established the standards.
I always,
people think I can just say
anything and never get sued.
That's what we're going to make the point
in the Covington case. No you can't.
If you say things that you know not to
be true that a jury can look at and say I
can objectives,
we verify this.
We the juries make determinations about
whether someone is involved in a hate
crime day.
They make a determination whether someone
has racially discriminatory animus or
motivation every day.
So if they're getting,
if someone's accusing
you of being a racist,
that should be actionable in law because
a jury can make that determination as a
matter of objective fact and the fair
banks case establishes precedent that you
can under certain circumstances
get legal remedy for that.
Got It.
Will never cease to amaze me that the
free speech crew or the people that have
to do certain things through law exact
such just to maintain free speech,
which aside, it sounds so counter
intuitive, but it's so fascinating to me.
So a couple of times you've mentioned Fox,
I think there's something
interesting happening here. Now,
has CNN or Msnbc ever put you on? No.
Have they ever asked you to come on?
CNN did way back about two years
ago. Okay. So CNN did two years ago.
MSNBC has not, Fox puts you on. Um,
now fox only puts me on and they put
me on with, no, I'd go on live shows.
They don't tell me to say anything.
I can say whatever the hell I want.
I often bring up liberal Craig
while I'm, while I'm on there. Uh,
but it seems also clear to me that partly
what's going on with the Tucker thing
is that they are really going for
Fox there. The plan is, all right,
we'll take out Tucker.
He's sort of the bravest or the
most outspoken or whatever it is.
But really then we'll make this about
going for foxes licensing and broadcast
abilities and everything else. You're
nodding. So I suspect you agree with me,
but I,
I'm amazed because it's like there's so
much lefty media and you never saw the
right trying to destroy
all the lefty immediate.
There's basically one fox and it doesn't
mean I love everything they're doing.
I don't, but you need some counterbalanced
don't. Yeah, absolutely. If
you have the approach of the inquisitional
Catholic Church or institutional
communism of a status variety,
then what?
What drives you crazy as the heresy
so you don't look at it and say, Geez,
how many fair balanced expressions do we
have on both sides to the acquisitional
Catholic Church?
There's only in the Catholic church
perspective and everybody else needs to be
burned at the stake for the status
Communist. Same dynamic there.
One state channel,
there's no alternative state channel.
There's no anti state channel. So when
you come at it from that perspective,
what Unites, say Alex Jones,
the Covington case and Fox is,
these are three institutions and they
represent different institutions that are
giving an independent narrative.
So when I was at Yale,
we did a history project that was actually
about why African Americans and poor
whites in the south,
we're often treated or,
or portrayed and very discriminatory
ways and cultural medium between 1,919 70
and what you find is that historically
those communities have alternative
narratives are grandparents and parents
tell stories different than say the
civics book version they learn
in third grade in public school.
And so consequently those groups are often
changed and censored and portrayed in
a negative light so that the broader
public audience wouldn't trust them to
listen to them or a react to them.
So the same thing as here.
Like you look at the Covington kids,
they represent private Catholic education.
What is private?
Catholic?
Catholic education is one of the last
institutions of independent thought
compared to say all the public state
schools and public institutions.
So it drives him crazy that they,
this institution that they can't control
their thoughts and mind off, right?
Because they don't have
access to that instance.
And then you even saw in the midst
of all this, I'm sure you saw this,
there was that guy from the New York Times
who said, I want to know your stories.
Remember, I forget what the Hashtag you
used was, but he wanted to know your,
you're Catholic.
It was like Hashtag Catholic schools
stories precisely because let's now New
York Times, let's go after them
once we're done with this thing.
So let's go after the
whole Catholic church.
Let's go after the Catholic
schools because we need
people to be afraid to be a
part of those goals, to be ashamed.
If they're connected to those schools,
parents worry that if their
skills are listed on their CV,
their kids' futures will be impaired
and not have these schools being
independent sources of thought outside
of the sort of cultural liberal, uh, uh,
hegemonic view.
And the same thing is true.
Like Alex Jones represent sort of an
independent part of the press. Uh,
Fox News represents institutional
part of the press that's independent,
that expresses its own perspective. That's
not part of the left majority. I mean,
CNN and Msnbc and ABC and NBC.
And CBS,
even if they're using public airwaves
are overwhelmingly on one side.
Same with PBS,
same with NPR and there's a lot of
good value and I watch all of them at
different times or listened
to them at different times,
but I want the other side
expressed and so why?
It's this fear of free expression,
this fear of free speech that's
leading to these censorship campaigns,
a shame campaigns, these
targeting campaigns, these
privacy invasion campaigns.
When I've told people is if you're ever
to the point where you're attacking a
person or trying to shame a
person trying to censor a person,
trying to invade their privacy
than what you're really looking,
you're doing as you're looking in
the mirror and telling yourself,
I've failed on the argument,
I can't persuade on ideas,
no audience would
actually believe my ideas.
So it's an admission of failure and
they're really resorting to these extreme
tactics because they're recognizing
they're losing in the public debate.
Do you think part of it also is
that it's intentional? Not now,
perhaps they're losing in the public
debate. I think that's probably,
you could debate that either way.
On one hand I'm very enthused about
sort of where we're at in this.
On the other hand it's very scary
too because you see this socialist,
whatever the hell that is arising.
So, but putting that aside,
do you think part of it is that they're
in doing it intentionally because they
just want to basically uh,
so chaos all over the place.
That partly what they need for
whatever their political goals are,
they need the system that has been pretty
freakin spectacular for 200 plus years
to appear chaotic. So they, so they, what
do they do? They sew chaos. It's very,
what's amazing is how paralleled is
the 1920 street violence in Europe.
So you see like a lot of the communist
tactics that were used back then and the
fascist tactics that were used back
then was in WWE were designed to sow
distrust in the system. So distrusted
the institution. That's it protected.
That's it.
Every day.
Now Aoc doing another thing about how
evil we are in Reagan's evenly capitalism,
capitalism to hate pedal.
Marya.
I think with like the combination you're
talking about where there's these bad
ideas that are spreading and yet
winning in the public debate,
what unites them is if
both sides get presented,
most people will take a
humanitarian decision,
will make a good choice based on their
common experience in their comments sets.
Whereas,
and so that's why this side that wants
to spread their ideas knows they can't
allow that open,
fair debate to happen or
those institutions to be
trusted and protected and
respected. If they can. D If they can
get people to no longer to not listen,
to not hear independent voices,
to be afraid to be a part
of independent institutions,
to feel ashamed if they're connected
to it, to say, Hey, if I'm a lawyer,
I represent this person, I'm going to
be attacked. If I'm, if I'm in the,
in the public arena and I
voiced an independent view,
I'm going to be targeted and harassed
and stalked and then the rest,
they want people to be
scared and intimidated to
express their ideas because I
think they know that in an in a
non chaotic open debate structure,
they don't win.
And I think that's what the recommend
because otherwise you don't have to resort
to these ridiculous tactics
and techniques. If your
ideas are great and popular,
you don't have to use chaotic
techniques. You don't have to, uh,
you don't have to try to censor people.
You don't have to attack people.
You don't have to say when to Tucker say
20 years ago on a, on a shock jock show,
you can say,
Hey,
I disagree with what he said yesterday
on Fox and I'm willing to debate them.
And Tucker is one of the
few people who says, Hey,
you can come on the show and we'll debate
quite literally what it statement said
exactly. If you don't like my ideas, let,
let's talk about exactly.
All right.
So I want to ask you something that
I think will sort of thread, oh,
you know what, I want to ask you one
other little tech thing and then,
and then something that I think that
will kind of bring us full circle here.
So one of the things is,
you know,
you see me do this all the time
where I have to publicly shame, uh,
youtube in Thai,
they're monetizing my video or making
sure people aren't being unsubscribed to
the rest of it and then ran
a certain amount of people
will say, but Dave, you're,
you're a libertarian or whatever.
You're not allowed to complain because
you don't want the government involved,
which is so idiotic because of course
I'm using my voice as a citizen.
That's what you're supposed to
do. Okay. Putting that aside, um,
do you think there is some interesting
legal mechanism if it was to be found out
that they were treating
traffic differently?
So that's a little bit different
than what we talked about earlier,
was talking about content specifically.
So you're saying this or that,
but what if they're actually turning
the screws just based on, uh,
not something you said,
but they have a general sort of a broad
sense that they don't want certain ideas
getting out there.
I think there are contractual principals,
equitable principles and consumer
protection principles that are in play.
So once you induce someone,
yeah,
you participate in your platform and
then you monetize their participation.
To me,
you have contractual obligations,
a equitable obligations you can't have
on just enrichment. So you say, Hey,
if you participate, we,
these are the rules.
And if as long as you abide by those
rules will make sure you share in the
profits, for example, of
monetizing your individual video.
And if they don't do that,
if they manipulate the algorithm,
they misrepresent facts,
they induce conduct and then only keep
the profit for themselves or use it for a
politicized purpose.
That's different than what they said.
Those are all consumer
protection violations,
equitable all violations and legal
violations sometimes recommend a remedy by
statutes, sometimes remedied
by common law. Well,
there's no reason for big
tech to be above the law
right there. There might also be some
legal thing related to their own board,
right? I mean, if they're doing
things that are not related, well,
if they're not the most profitable
thing, they're bored me. I don't know
exactly what it was. Right?
Shareholders can take action,
so they're going to be a
derivative suits by shareholders.
They could go to the board,
but they can also bring derivative legal
claims against the institution saying
they're not promoting the best profit.
They're creating undue
legal risk and liability.
They're not behaving in a
matter consistent with their
professional obligations
and their contractual obligations
to their, their own investors.
And so they can also bring action.
And in fact, the left leg went up.
I told a lot of people is, look at what
the left has done between the seventies.
In 2000,
you'll see a lot of legal roadmaps for
how to go at what they're doing now.
So they were with some of
the, you know, the, uh,
on the apartheid
campaigns in South Africa,
they targeted different people
using shareholders suits
using shareholder claims,
using shareholder complaints to remedy
that of people who are profiting from the
apartheid system in South Africa.
Why can't we do the same thing now
based on the same legal theories,
same factual predicates as the,
as what's taking place here,
which is inconsistent with their
obligations and promises to people.
I guess partly in, this brings
me to the, to the last question,
it's partly about bravery.
You need citizens who were brave enough.
You need lawyers who are brave enough
and they've created a system where
everyone is afraid.
Because the,
when I go out speaking to college
campuses or even I do Q and, a,
when I'm doing standup or wherever I go,
the question I get more than anything
else is I'm afraid to say what I think and
what should I do.
And it's usually students that are saying
I want to get a grade cause I want to
get out, I want to get to Grad school or
whatever. And I always think it's like,
man, if everyone's thinking
this, if we all just stopped,
if we all just stopped acquiescing to it,
we could actually change this thing
like that. So my question to you is you,
and you mentioned your father before,
but why? Why are you willing to do this?
Why are you willing to
put your ass on the line?
Where does this come from in you?
So it's two things. One, it's, it's
growing up. So grew up poor in the south,
got a scholarship to private schools,
scholarship to Yale. When I was at Yale,
they tried to get rid of
poor students who were there,
let a protest by leaving Yale in order
to get them to reinstate their policies.
And I saw there, I was like,
I'm one kid, I'm 19 years old,
I'm challenging all of Yale University,
which wasn't exactly a small institution.
And just by leaving the school and
getting public attention for it,
I got them to reverse their
policies and protect poor students.
Same access that I had to a rights to
full financial aid rights to be treated in
a nondiscriminatory manner
in the application process.
So as a, at a young age,
I learned why one person can change the
world. When I was a real little kid,
I loved Medgar Evers and Medgar Evers
had this great quote where they asked him
why he wasn't afraid to die and he said,
most men die a thousand deaths every day.
I'm only going to die once.
And I was little kid. I was like, I
want to be at Medgar Evers. It's like,
that is so powerful. That is so
important. That's so influential.
And you realize that one
person can make a difference.
And when you realize one
person can make a difference,
if they know it here and act on it here,
then you realize that that that's
the power. That's the passion.
That's what leads you to want to
change the world, not be afraid of.
I've had rogue agents threatened me,
a IRS,
people put me on audit every
other year whenever I want a case.
I've rogue judges threatened me.
I've had people say that they were going
to try to put me on a bogus criminal
investigation.
I've had every smear campaign known to
man had bomb threats coming because of my
Covington case representation,
and none of it concerns me because if
you understand that you really have the
powers one person to make a
real difference in the world,
then other people will start to recognize
that and they'll act on their power.
They'll voice their,
their abilities,
they'll use their capabilities
to make a meaningful difference,
and that's how the world
changes and that's how the
world becomes a better place.
That is how you end an interview. Can we
smoke one of those cigars? He right here,
right? We're done here. Follow Robert.
I have a feeling you'll be back here.
I have a feeling that's going to happen
on Twitter at Barnes underscore law.